[Music]
welcome to star talk i'm neil degrasse
tyson you're a personal astrophysicist
in this episode we feature a compilation
of things you thought you knew
each segment along with my co-host chuck
nice we dig into a topic that you
might think you understand but do you
really
what's the difference between mass
weight and density for example
well let's find out
jack good to see you again good to see
you what's happening what do we got
what's going on i can't wait to hear i'm
still at it you know i i i lose sleep at
night thinking i gotta tell this to
chuck okay just so you know i'm thinking
i don't i don't believe that
i don't believe that for one second
but i'll take it i will take it
i just got to straighten some things out
okay i think that
they
some people not everybody but some
people i think have this all confused
and i want to straighten it out all
right it's the difference between mass
weight and density
all right well okay now for
without a doubt there are there's a lot
of people that get that confused i just
want to okay so
generally if you go on a diet you want
to lose weight right absolutely so what
it's not what actually what's actually
happening it is but it's not
the root of what's happening what you're
really doing is you're losing mass
you want there to be less of you
tomorrow than there is today
if only i could keep the parts that i
want
if if you consume
fewer calories
today then you
burned calories today
you will lose weight
okay it's that simple okay i i've joked
about this a a weight loss book written
by a physicist would have one sentence
consume calories at a slower rate
than you burn them
that's the entire
that's it but so if tomorrow you want
less of you than there is today you're
losing mass
okay the mass is the sum of all the
particles that comprise chuck
okay that's your mass
i could take you and put you on the moon
you'll weigh less
but you still have all of your particles
okay then that is where i need to move
when can we do this
so if you weigh 180 pounds i don't know
how much you weigh let's call you 180
pounds on earth okay on the moon you
weigh one-sixth of that right so you
weigh 30 pounds
so if chuck you want to lose 150 pounds
your nutritional say no chuck you'll die
no i'm just going to go to the moon for
a day weigh myself i'm 150
so your weight is not itself the measure
of how much mass you have
okay all right you also weigh a little
less
at the top of a mountain because you're
farther away from the center of the
earth than you do in death valley where
you're at a low point
relative to other places on earth so if
you get on a scale at the top of everest
you're going to weigh less than you
would on that same scale
in death valley in that thought correct
okay less okay people at the equator
weigh a little less
than they would if they're visiting
santa claus oh that's because there's a
lot of sun down there and they got to
stay in bikini shape all year long
that's fine right that's really what
it's about so the equator is the speed
at which you are moving is faster than
at other latitudes people on the equator
moving about a thousand miles an hour we
here in new york we're moving about 800
miles an hour so that centrifugal force
makes them lighter than we are
gotcha so all of this is affecting your
weight but it's not affecting your mass
okay so if you want to lose weight in
any zone then lose mass
all right just to be clear about that
all right so weight loss programs are
actually mass loss programs okay and so
weight then is is about forces then it's
not it's not about it's the definition
of weight wait is the force of gravity
on you well who's gravity are we talking
about earth or this or or the sun or
venus or the moon so you find out what
is what are the conditions of that force
of gravity on you in that place
not only among planets but even
different places on earth
and then
you've got your weight
and that weight is related to how many
molecules of chuck exist
but in the end of the day if you want
to weigh less what you really mean is
you want less mass you want less chuck
tomorrow than you have today so just
want to put that out there something
better right everybody can agree on that
let's check
it's like
we didn't we don't we don't show you the
the mails we the mail we get uh when
will chuck disappear
we will hold those from you jack okay so
now
we talk about how heavy something is
okay okay so when we think of something
floating on water generally the idea of
it being heavy is not
that's not the same thought correct no
if it's heavy it sinks okay
so now
let's take
uh you know uh you know let's go to
who's the guy who splits
wood
sections into firewood
whatever that is okay go take one of
these
bunion guys paul bunyan cylinders of
wood
okay
it's going to be really heavy we know
this
take it
plunk it down in a swimming pool what
happens to it it floats it floats even
though it's super heavy okay it is heavy
but it floats right okay
so
how do you get around that what do we
let's let's give more examples of that
okay
um
ivory soap
nobody
what okay
yes ivory soap floats right and as far
as i know it's the only soap that floats
i did an experiment when i was younger
but i haven't checked it lately but i
did test this yeah ivy subfloats all the
others so think okay okay so
why that should be a selling point i
don't know but it was in its day it was
a selling point and then it was it was
88 100 percent pure
right
and it was like pure what right exactly
you know i i remember thinking as a kid
but any every so long predates me but i
remember thinking all of that all right
so
heavy
cream
is lighter than skim milk
heavy cream is lighter than skim milk
and you know why because it floats on
the skimmer that's how you get skim milk
there you go the cream floats between
rises to the top you skim it off you got
some heavy cream so we say it's heavier
but we don't really mean heavier
heavier to me is the absolute weight how
heavy is it can i pick it up what do you
mean it's thinner with with no it's not
thinner well it's more less viscous
less dense okay this viscosity says no i
should have added that we'll get to
viscosity in a minute okay
heavy cream is less dense
than water
than skim milk right
if you are less dense than something
else you float there you go there it is
nothing else nothing else matters
right okay
you will float
so heavy cream
is we would say it's lighter than skim
milk but that's a little deceptive if
you want to be precise you say it's less
dense than skim milk right therefore it
floats
okay
so this is the fight i was in a fight
the encounter i had in a pasadena coffee
shop when i ordered hot chocolate with
whipped cream and the hot chocolate came
and there's no whipped cream anywhere to
be found and i said um server where is
the whipped cream they said oh we put it
on i said where is it oh it must have
sunk to the bottom
at which point i said
either
you are lying
or the laws of physics that apply to the
rest of the universe do not apply in
your coffee shop
and so he got all gruffy and
he went by and brought cream with him
okay
and then plunked it down and it took one
bob and instead of and it floated i said
thank you for my whipped cream
mm-hmm
now i don't know if that became like a
story
you know because i'm sure wait staff
tell stories
right but that's what happened so he's
thinking it's heavy it probably fell to
the bottom and would choose to lie
and rather
lie about it thinking that i didn't know
what the hell i was talking about and
when you took it away you looked at him
and you went
science
you just got scienced you just got
scienced
science
so
a couple more things about weight
mass and
density so
um
you realize that logs float all right
right so if you're going to say if i
want it but i don't float very well all
right so if i want to float on the water
i'm going to use a log
so why don't i get a big log and then
hollow it out
okay okay these are the first canoes
right okay the canoes are made of wood
you hot and you know the canoe canoe's
gonna float i'm gonna get in it and
we're good to go
well why don't you make a boat out of
steel
well i can't do that because the steel
will sink that's not a boat that's not
gonna work
no let's be clever about it okay by the
way if you make a boat out of steel is
then impervious to the weapons of other
boats
oh my gosh what a military advance this
would be this in the 19th century i
think it was
where the first people figured out i can
make a boat out of things that are
impervious to cannon balls right
and so whereas if you make a boat out of
wood then it just busts through the wood
right so what matters is not the density
of the material
what matters is the density of
everything that is sitting below water
so if i create a hull
only the outer edge of the hole is made
of steel what's everything else inside
the hull made out of
something else
no uh it's air air
air it's a it's like a ballast it's okay
no no ballast has this different purpose
right right because you want to
stabilize dave okay so you put some
other you put some heavy things just at
the very bottom of the hull and that's
okay in position and that keep that
keeps the that keeps it in positions
that would be ballast okay and a lot of
the cobblestone in lower manhattan that
built the roads was ballast in ships
that came from europe
okay and then they offload that and
build built roads with it sweet yeah
yeah so a lot of it no and other things
as well but
point is
you so now
the the density is
what is the total mass
divided by the total volume
okay so that's grams per cubic
centimeter or pounds per cubic inch
that's that's so those are the units of
density so let me get some units out
there so we've got the units of mass or
grams and kilograms and i'm not going to
tell you the unit of mass for the
english system okay
um and the unit
people say why not tell me
why not
no so seriously what is why wouldn't you
give out the uh okay the unit of mass in
the english system is slug
no yes that's why i told you i told you
not to ask me so yeah so so the mass
grams kilograms this sort of thing
volume is the cubic of some of some
length so cubic inch
cubic centimeter cubic meter those are
names the density is the mass divided by
the volume
mass divided by volume okay so just see
how that works so if i have a certain
amount of mass and i put it in a smaller
and smaller volume it becomes more and
more dense yeah yeah so what happens
that if the denominator gets smaller
then the number gets bigger bigger so we
get higher and higher density because
you're cramming all this into a smaller
volume right the volume gets bigger and
bigger and bigger for the same amount of
mass right then the density gets lower
and lower and lower you get beach balls
that's another right it's spreading it
out spreading it out so what i've done
with the steel
is i've put air in between the two steel
sides of the boat
so now the density the effective density
is the mass of the steel plus the mass
of the air divided by the volume and
when i do that i get something that's
less dense than water and the whole
thing floats so then it goes it will
only go down a certain amount in the
water certain amount that's it that's it
and it but it will float that's how you
make
boats out of steel and that's how
military ships were first
put together i mean cool the the the
indestructible type right so then you
needed a weapon that can destroy the
steel and then you have the
the the eternal contest of warring arms
raised arms race exactly exactly
so
there you have it chuck so so you have
mass density so anything that floats on
water is simply less dense than water
right it doesn't matter how much it
weighs or what it is it just has to be
less dense than water does nothing else
matters wow that's cool and it could
weigh a zillion pounds and it'll just
it'll still flow which is why my uncle
edward floats
that's a big man that's a fat brother
i'm telling you he's a big fat buddy
well so so fat is less dense than than
water and bones and muscle is more dense
so if you float every time you just have
way more fat than muscle and bone well
there you have it
good for you
uncle eddie
that's why it's no accident that that
marine mammals have a lot of fat right
okay the blubber like as they call it
right so there's a lot of fat there and
that gives them buoyancy in the water
yes all right oh by the way what's an
ice cube made out of
water but why do they float
because they have air inside of them i
don't know no
but sometimes they do but that's not oh
no they expand they expand it's less
dense so it's less dense the water it
used to be now takes up more volume
right so bigger vine makes it less than
some ice floats there you go you know we
should do an explainer on ice expanding
we should do that
we should do that not now not now we can
oh why not well no i guess we're done
we're done here we're done here all
right well looking forward to ice
expanding there okay
thanks for doing this with me chuck of
course always a pleasure we got to take
a quick break but when we come back
we're going to talk about
you guessed it
ice expanding
why ice floats on star talk
it's things you thought you knew
addition
we'll see you in a moment
chuck we're back
yes we are
and this was interesting there are
certain things that we just
experience in our lives and never even
think to question it
true because it's in our everyday life
and and and and some things you don't
want to know the answers
that's different some things are just
left unexplained unknown
i'm not i'm not gonna mess with not
gonna go there no no this one you can
ask a simple question why does ice float
right have you ever asked that
i have
you have okay i have yeah i mean because
when you think about it it's water but
you're putting it in water yeah liquid
it's water liquid in water right it's
water and water so and usually when you
cool something down it shrinks
okay it becomes more dense
tell me about it
so it becomes more dense
and so you would think that a cooler
version of some liquid
would be
you know if you shrink the same mass
down to a smaller volume it's more dense
that right all ice cubes would sink to
the bottom of your glass as a matter of
fact
in certain parts of
the oceans i'm gonna
where you have what they call um oh god
now i forget the name of it it just it
was just on the tip of my tongue but the
coldest water
stays
at the bottom of the ocean yeah we're
not there yet
oh we're actually going to talk about
that yes
oh sweet oh my gosh we're totally going
there okay forget about that
okay all right all right so
so a peculiar thing happens to water
when it changes state okay a change of
state means you go from liquid to solid
solid to gas get so we have water and
there it is
when it freezes
the water molecule
in order to freeze takes up more volume
than does the water molecule in a liquid
state
so the water expands by about ten
percent
nice okay and roughly you can think
about that as if you are
if you expand ten percent and you go
back into your liquid you will bob with
about ten percent of your volume above
the water
okay and ninety percent below so just
put put an ice cube in your glass it's
easier to see this if it's in a cube
shape rather than in those crescent
shapes or other things but if you take a
cube and put it in there 10 percent will
be above the water and 90 will be below
all right hold on
oh
okay
all right
okay okay all right
i just happen to have a glass of water
here oh you do and are your is your ice
in it are they cubes
oh my goodness look at that that's
awesome yes this is a cube okay okay
and you just see it's got like a little
surface you can't see it but it's got a
little surface because the top part is
clear i don't know why but it's just
like you said it's like it's bobbing up
yeah it's stopping but most of it is
below yeah so check a little bit about
it's not happening because i said so
it's happening because this is how the
universe works no
no you're a wizard
stop lying
now here's an interesting fact if you
take that same glass of water with that
one ice cube in it and fill it as much
as you possibly can
so that not another drop can go in it
without spilling over the edge
right if you do that okay the ice will
be sitting above that level
above the lip of the glass
right and you might be worried oh my
gosh
i better get a coaster because when this
melts it's going to overflow
but no when it melts it's going to take
up the volume that it's already
displacing in the water itself and it's
not going to get any higher than it
currently is right
this is why
the
arctic ice sheets
in the arctic so where santa claus is
right it is ice that is floating on the
water
in the future where global warming melts
the entire northern cap
when that happens it will not that alone
will not increase the sea levels of the
world
because the ice is already floating in
the bathtub of that water that's correct
so the ice you need to worry about is
the ice that's on land oh that runoff
the runoff okay that ice
you melt that you're directly adding
watercolor that's on greenland and
primarily
greenland and antarctica so that then
starts
flooding the oceans and raising raising
the sea levels okay so but by the way uh
232 feet if that were to happen
oh thank you for that number yeah i
think i tweeted once that if you if you
do that then the water level will go up
to the left elbow of the statue of
liberty yeah the one that's holding um i
think it's the declaration of
independence uh just in her arm and yeah
and that basically you lose manhattan
and basically every other coastal city
of which
where you find most of the great cities
of the world are on the water's edge so
anyhow so so so that's why ice floats
but there's more going on here you could
delay
the freezing of the ice it freezes at 32
degrees or zero degrees celsius
you can make it freeze at like one
degree below zero
if you put it under pressure
okay yeah and it's good so it gets
colder and it says i want to freeze i
have to get bigger i have to get bigger
i'm not letting you
so then it doesn't it doesn't change the
state okay but if you keep taking the
temperature lower and lower
under pressure the isis says the ice
says
okay and i will expand no matter what
you're doing and boom
pipes break yeah
okay so i don't know why i'm hap i don't
know why
[Laughter]
what am i talking about that's
disastrous you're happy that you you now
understand the full dynamics of that so
it would be very hard
for ice at 32 degrees to break a pipe
because the pipes are made of typically
they're made of copper or some strong
metal and so it'll keep it squeezed down
and say no you're not freezing at 30 no
you're not going to let you freeze at 30
degrees no not at 29. oh 25 degrees
and it is stronger than
the pipes and you just break the pipes
and by the way at that moment all the
pipes are frozen there's no leakage
when do you have leakage
when the temperature goes up again and
then the ice melts out of the path and
then the water flies ugh
so the the the act of broken pipes in
most cases is not the moment where you
get the leak
because the ice is there the ice is
there plugging the pipes
it's later on when the ice moves out of
the way
so so this is the power of freezing ice
now last point i want to make
is well how about the density of water
just as water does it change density yes
it does okay
as you
cool water
it takes up slightly less and less
volume
hardly noticeable if you're just
swimming in it or just looking look at
this
if you heat water it takes up slightly
more volume
and a lot of the increased sea level
rise in the future of global warming is
simply because the oceans are warmer
and they're warmer they they take up you
know let's say it's one percent more
depth
right but you come but what is one
percent more depth in the middle of the
ocean where it's three miles deep okay
if it's one percent more depth by the
time you get to the shoreline you have
flooding
right okay so let's cool the water it
gets colder and colder and colder it
begins to shrink
well at some point that has to turn
around because eventually it's going to
become ice where it's bigger there is a
point
where ice is at its densest
and it's three degrees celsius
really okay so
you so you cool water at the surface
it's denser than the water below it and
so that cool water drops and it goes to
the bottom
okay
and it stays there
you keep trying to cool water at the top
and it goes down to the bottom but what
happens now you're cooling water now the
water is two degrees celsius or one
degree celsius it begins to stay on top
then it hits zero degrees celsius it
freezes on top on top
keeping the three degree water at the
bottom
right
preserving
all aquatic life
over the winter time
that's why you don't have bird's eye
frozen fish once the uh once the lake
freezes
if ice sank
oh my gosh you would freeze lakes from
the bottom up you through that top layer
we go to the bottom and slowly but
surely all the fish would be swimming in
an ever thinner layer of water until you
just go and scoop them all up and that's
the last fish that would ever exist in
that lake
oh what a what a bear's dream
no they're hibernating they're missing
that's true yeah so so
this
feature of water
protects life over the winter aquatic
life over the winter wow
and once you form the ice layer on the
top it actually insulates the bottom you
get really cold on top but that does
that how long will that take to transmit
through a thick layer of ice it takes a
long time by then it's daytime compared
to night or spring has come and so you
rarely if ever do you end up freezing an
entire lake and it's because of this
property of water that ice floats the
ice is less dense than water
that is amazing and it's it's pretty
cool that this this becomes like its own
little closed ecosystem where the ice
freezes on top insulates the water
beneath it so that all the life is
protected it's protected
that's amazing it's basically it so this
is a feature of this fact about
water the water molecule one other thing
it's what enables you to ice skate
okay because the reverse is true so i if
i have an ice cube and it's sitting at
let's say 30 degrees okay right and it's
frozen so minus one let's say celsius if
i squeeze it
if i squeeze it
under pressure i'm trying to put it into
a smaller volume
ice won't let you do that
right but
if i press it really hard what's the
only way the ice can respond to you to
go into a smaller volume
it's got to become water it's got to
become water so you can squeeze melt
something even at subfreezing oh my god
that's
that's how you get the great ice cube
there no ice spheres for drinking scotch
what you just said they take a copper
press
and i'm too excited about this i'm sorry
this is this bar information that you're
sharing i know i know now what's up now
we're talking about scotch and drinking
i'm like oh my god uh and you don't even
have your scotch voice today right now
exactly yeah exactly
[Laughter]
when you're skating on ice
okay the blade
is the way it's it's sharpened is it has
a very sharp edge on one side and on the
other on the left and on the right hand
side so you go on an edge and skaters
know about this on your inside edge or
on the outside edge that is a lot of
pressure we got to do a whole other
explainer video on force and pressure
but that pressure is so high that it
actually melts the ice in place
and the skate glides on a bead of water
wow that's great
that's why that's why ice is slippery on
ice skates
yeah so so yeah i mean that same premise
you just
um um um demonstrated
when you get a they make spears of ice
for drinking i love ice yeah i spheres
and they use for some reason copper i
don't know why but they used copper or
brass one or the other and
they just put the ice in the sphere and
they let the brass
it's a big weight
it's a brass weight or a copper weight
and it just
presses down on the ice and then the ice
melts into a ball
that is so cool oh okay all right so
they take
okay so to shaping the sphere from the
pressure on a shape that's not a sphere
that's right oh okay yeah so under
pressure yes it will melt under pressure
it melts yet yet when you relieve the
pressure it freezes instantly it freezes
right because it's because it's the it's
the below freezing temperature that you
started with exactly and then you just
have a bit a literal ball of ice okay
chuck i don't go to many bars i've never
seen this i trust that in your bar
hopping this is something
feature okay i'm gonna have to i'm gonna
have to get you out man i gotta get more
off
i'll have to get you out of the house
all right so that's that's it chuck
that's uh ice is less dense than water
nice i'm always fascinated how we end up
in these great places from something
so
seemingly um mundane
as a cube of ice or ice melting and next
time we do this we got to do this with
one of your spheres of ice and i want to
do a whole explainer video with you and
your scotch voice
oh absolutely
not a problem
no i don't i'll start on it right now
right now
wait a minute we got this
okay next on star talks things you
thought you knew edition you won't hear
an entire explainer on chuck's scotch
whiskey voice but you will hear us talk
about the concept of weight
in space
we'll see you in a bit
okay neil here's one for you oh okay
okay
all right so you give me a week rest
here but you're not okay oh not at all
no
no rest for the weary
don't rest for the weary all right what
do you have okay so
in space
how much does an astronaut weigh
you see weight is a is it's not what you
think it is remember we did one of these
where we talked about mass versus weight
do you remember that right we talked
about that and i said you want to weigh
less
go to the top of a mountain okay you'll
burn calories getting up there so you'll
get you'll get you lose a little bit of
weight for that but at the top of the
mount you're farther away from earth
center and you run the math you weigh a
little bit less it out nothing
significant not nothing large but a
measurable amount okay right it's not
going to replace it's not going to
replace your p90x workout exactly thank
you right
not only that you you don't weigh as
much in air as you would in a vacuum
okay because air has a buoyant force
that makes you weigh a little less
than you would if there was no air
around you we don't even think about
that that doesn't even but but a helium
balloon knows everything about that
right that's so funny you remember that
right healing balloon cares what the
buoyant force of the air is on it
because it wants to float at the top of
the air
okay so i ask you you know what and what
do you weigh when you're in the water
if i say chuck what do you weigh and
you'll probably give me your weight on
dry land right but your weight in the
water since you're about the density of
water your weight is basically zero
really some people float some people
sink and on average people just sort of
bob there right that means you weigh
nothing
that's you're weightless in the water in
fact nasa trains astronauts
in a huge swimming pool
to simulate what it'd be like to be
weightless in space
do you realize there's a swimming pool
big enough to submerge an entire mock-up
of the hubble space telescope
and to put in astronauts in there with
tools to work on it okay that's the pool
i want i want to swim in that's a
bad-ass pool right that's it i think
it's the biggest swimming pool in the
world actually yeah that that pool is
dope okay yeah and it's and i'm sure
it's more than three feet because
but there's no diving board right right
yeah there was a diving board
that pool would be amazing let me dive
down the tube of the hubble telescope
and if they had a water slide too oh my
god
so here's the thing when we think of the
blue whale for example the largest
animal there ever was
by the way point of pride
blue whale is a mammal okay so mammals
have the record they're bigger than
dinosaurs ever were we say well how much
does it weigh and you look it up and you
google it it'll give you a weight
for the for that whale a full-grown
whale but no
excuse me
that's if you took it out of the water
put it on land and put it on a scale
right but that's not where it lives
that's not its environment no by the way
i'd like to see that scale you'd have to
you have to weigh it in the water and
when you do that it weighs zero
that's why whales can just hang there
yeah it is looked and it's such a
beautiful thing okay if they had weight
in the water they would sink
right so they're just there they're very
close to zero so they still have all the
mass so i'm saying we we don't really
think of the word weight the way we
ought to in in a sort of physically
significant way that that's i just want
to put that out there okay
whales weigh nothing
in the water and they don't hang out on
land so the weight on land is kind of
irrelevant to us and to them
okay so really we should find a way to
think about how much mass they contain
rather than simply how much they weigh
and usually that's what people mean when
they say that right but i just want to
try to be clear about that
physically clear about that and whales
are a lot of blubber so
you know muscle weighs more than fat so
probably not a lot of mass there no no
it's a lot no
no there's still a lot of man there's
still a lot of mass i know
i'm just trying to i'm just trying to
not body shame the whale that's oh
i don't want to body shame the whale
that you're the one who said they got
blubber you started it
[Laughter]
all right so now
uh astronauts
in orbit
weigh
precisely zero
precise zero
okay
and it's not because they're far away
from earth
as i've said in other others of these
how far away is the astronaut from earth
in if they visit the space station
three-eighths of an inch
above this a schoolroom globe if you
shrunk it all down to that be
three-eighths of an inch away right
that's close it's a fingernail right so
finger yeah the width of your finger uh
less even yes
yeah yeah yeah so so that's the distance
right so you can't tell me oh they're in
space they've left gravity
no
no if you've left gravity by being in
orbit then what the hell is holding the
moon in orbit okay
right what do you think the moon is
orbiting of course the moon feels earth
gravity and it could also be you know
the moon it's kind of sweet on the earth
so
[Laughter]
so uh and there was a a a well-known
uh
news announcer back in the 1960s who
when the apollo astronauts were headed
to the moon for the first time they said
the apollo astronauts as of 8 30 this
morning
at whatever time it was have officially
left the gravitational pull of the earth
it's like no
they actually said that on on this yes
yes yes yes you can't leave the
gravitational pull of the earth on route
to the moon
if the moon is orbiting earth right okay
so i don't think they thought that
through and in fact in the equations
earth's gravitational field
gets less and less and less as you go
out in space but it never actually hits
zero until you get to infinity
okay
so
you tell me when you get to infinity
call me and we'll talk
so
uh the reason why they're weightless has
nothing to do with their distance from
earth uh it has to do with the fact that
they are falling towards earth
wow free fall so i put you in an
elevator shaft and a tall building and i
cut cut the cable right okay no i put
you in the elevator you're just standing
there right so here we go and you're
standing on a scale that has a spring so
you're squeezing the spring and it shows
your weight but let's just use round
numbers to say you're 200 pounds okay so
there you are the scale registers 200
pounds because you're squeezing the
scale okay gravity's pulling on you to
squeeze the spring
to indicate the measure okay now
now i
now i cut the elevator cable
okay so what now happens the elevator
drops
right the scale drops right you drop
right
all three of you
are now falling at exactly the same rate
right
so there is no
net force of u on the spring right
there's right so while you are falling
you weigh zero and this the scale will
say zero because i will say zero because
there will be no compression to measure
correct and here's another measure of
that you ready
let's say you're in an elevator and it's
just standing there and you're holding
uh you know
from my professor angle i say you're
holding a piece of chalk but no one
holds chalk so
what are you holding find a
holding a ball okay okay there you go if
you let go of the ball it drops to the
ground right
okay right in fact
in fact
drop it is synonymous with let go
because gravity does that work right the
phrase drop it you just let go right you
could just say let go and it means drop
it all right because we live in a
gravitational field that that doesn't
work in a cop movie though it's just
sorry let go the gun
let
let go
they do say drop them all they do
yeah all right and unless you're black
in which case they just that's a whole
other thing all right so let's go
so
so now what happened now i cut the
elevator cable
now you begin to fall now you're
standing there holding the ball
now let go of the ball right well you're
falling
the ball is falling at exactly the same
rate you are so it'll appear to float in
front of your face right but really
you're not floating you're just falling
everybody's falling but from your point
of view you're saying to yourself
wow it's floating i'm floating
i you do this until you die when the
elevator hits the bottom
right exactly it's a beautiful
experiment until you're a pile of goo
when the elevator hits the bottom yeah
and the ball survives of course the ball
bounces yes right you know
so here's the deal okay
i'm telling you the astronauts in orbit
around the earth are falling towards
earth right
in free fall just like you in the
elevator cable that i just cut right all
right now the now the reason why they
don't hit earth because they have really
fast sideways motion
so watch what happens okay
watch what happens here you are in an
elevator and you know you're gonna hit
the ground and you're gonna die okay now
i'm gonna say all right let's take this
elevator
and move it sideways
really fast okay well how fast should it
go let's move it sideways so fast
so by the time it drops a foot let's say
earth has curved a foot away from it
you drop
five feet earth has curved five feet
away from it
so whatever distance you have fallen
the curvature of earth because you're
traveling so fast downrange the
curvature of the earth cancels it out it
cancels it out wow precisely that's
perfect and there's one speed
for which that is true
and that is if you go sideways five
miles per second
wow on earth
so you go sideways five miles per second
at that speed you will free fall to
earth at exactly the same rate earth
curves away from you you will never hit
earth and we have another word for this
because rather if you never hit earth
this will just keep going right you just
go come back where you started and you
keep going we have a word for that it's
called orbit
so orbit is free fall
with high sideways velocity around the
earth and that's why
people say oh we launched the rocket
into space today what you really did was
have you ever watched a rocket more than
just a couple of minutes after the
launch pad yeah okay okay what does it
do it's down range it starts to careen
off like most of the energy that's
launching that rocket is not to get it
into space no it's to give it that
sideways motion at five miles per second
so that it can sustain an orbit around
the earth
that's pretty dope it's totally dope and
you know who first figured this out my
man no don't even say it
isaac newton
my man isaac newton okay he drew a
picture he had earth okay and he drew a
little mountain and he had a little was
it a cannon or something at the top of
the mountain he said what happens if you
shoot the cannon out sideways okay and
it just hits the ground suppose you give
it more speed it'll go farther before it
hits the ground let's giving it more and
more speed and as you follow this
diagram the cannonball continues around
the earth but still hits earth
is there a speed where it goes all the
way around the earth does not hit earth
and it hits you in the back of the head
but you duck and the cannonball
continues
is there a speed for that yes and he
figured out what that speed is and
that's the speed of orbit around the
earth and like i said that's five miles
per second wow isaac newton invented
orbits with that simple diagram
and in so doing he
he merged our understanding of falling
objects
with the orbit of the moon around the
earth
this was his revelation when he watched
the apple fall he didn't hit him on the
head by the way that's right he watched
the apple fall straight down and he sees
the moon in orbit around the earth and
he said this is exactly the same
phenomenon wow except the moon is going
sideways so that it doesn't hit the
earth so the moon in earth's gravity is
weightless because it's in free fall
around the earth there you go oh wow
that's that's amazing okay so now i just
gotta i gotta put this out there the
movie add astra okay yes with uh matt
damon no no no i'm sorry sorry wait
don't tell me don't tell me uh it's
because that's the marxism
uh the leading man
yeah um that's brad pitt
looking for his dad who is tommy lee
jones
correct correct okay so
in that movie um they knew correctly
that you don't have to wait three days
to get to the moon that's that's like a
sort of a
minimum energy transfer to the moon
where you fire your rockets until you
have enough to sort of get into the
moon's pull and then the moon pulls you
down so you use minimal fuel but if you
want to get there you can get there in a
few hours you just use a lot of
fuel okay
if your rockets are burning on your ship
you have weight on that ship
because it's accelerating towards you
right okay that is no different from you
having weight standing here on earth
because earth the force of gravity is
that same phenomenon right okay
so so if i go on a ship and i i don't
care where i am in the universe if i'm
accelerating the ship
at 9.8 meters per second per second
that's the acceleration of gravity on
earth if i accelerate the ship at that
speed in any direction i can stand up at
the bottom of this ship and it is though
i'm standing on earth
and what i'm telling you is that in that
movie they show people jetting around
the solar system because it's the future
and the rockets are always uh ignited
and everyone's floating in the ship
no no
no didn't it wouldn't have worked like
that totally wrong
okay
so what would happen is they would have
been pinned up against pinned up against
the thing if it's strong acceleration
that's right because what's happening is
at any given moment the whole system is
going at a certain speed okay but if
it's accelerating then the ship is
accelerating towards you right and so
it's going to come up against you and
put a scale between there you're going
to have an equivalent weight on that
ship wow so space is not inherently a
weightless place unless you are free
falling towards one place or another and
to make that happen you can't have
rockets firing
just gotta have a sideways motion going
on around the earth around the earth or
you launch from from the earth and you
reach up and you turn off your rockets
and then you
fall towards the moon right then you're
weightless that whole way but the moment
you turn on the rockets you you're gonna
pin to the side the back the front
and so in fact they're long-term plans
to go to mars if you don't want to lose
bone mass and all this and you don't
want to rotate the ship you accelerate
halfway there okay right
and then you have to decelerate
otherwise you'll miss more so what they
do is then they turn the rocket around
right okay then you decelerate but in
either case you can have the equivalent
of one g one g and you can have earth
gravity the whole way wow look at that
and you'll get there like it i've weeks
a couple of weeks
that's accelerated and i think maybe
even faster rather than the nine ten
months that it normally takes yeah
that's that's the premise behind the
expanse the movie the expanse okay no i
mean not the movie the the series
serious that's next to my on my on my
binge list yeah definitely
very last thing because we're out of
time okay uh so just to be clear there
are three ways to
to simulate gravity one of them is just
be on earth and let's call that real
gravity okay another way is to
accelerate something at the acceleration
of gravity right and the third way is
you can rotate something and then the
centrifugal force
that wants to fling you outwards that
you'll read that as a gravitational
force and so that's where you'd have a
ring so if you did rotate a ring you
you'd walk around on the outer rim as
they shown famously in the movie 2001
right a space odyssey
so so there you have it going into space
does not automatically make you
weightless
only a free fall towards an object will
very cool and the thing that i took away
from this talk most is
if you shoot a cannon off a side of a
mountain at uh five miles per second you
should dunk duck
duck 88 minutes later yeah that's how
long it'll take
that's cool
oh by the way that calculation uh we're
not gonna get into it here but i'll just
tell you if you dig a hole through the
earth going through the center and
coming out the other side
and then you drop something through
it'll fall towards the center overshoot
the center come out the other side and
if nobody grabs it it'll then bob back
down
and come back into your hand that round
trip also takes 88 minutes
nice yes
yes
oh man well i'm going to start i'm going
to start digging now because i got one
more one more you ready just while we're
on the subject
earth's equator feels a little bit of
centrifugal force so you weigh a little
bit less on the equator than you do at
other latitudes so
if i speed up earth you'll weigh less
and less and less and less
sweet there's a speed with which i can
spin earth where you weigh so much less
that you weigh zero
okay i'm going to know what speed that
is
at the equator you know what speed that
78 rpm
chuck how old are you
so that's speed so if you if so if the
equator makes one full spin
in 88 minutes
right you're weightless there you go
you'll just hover over the ground and so
basically at that point you're in orbit
around the earth
it's all the same number right that's
what's cool about it
that is cool
once every 88 minutes everyone on the
equator is weightless
sweet
got to end it there chuck all right that
was cool i'm going to ecuador
what a coincidence they're named ecuador
and they're on the equator who would
have thought
all right this has been another star
talk explainer chuck always good to have
you always a pleasure neil degrasse
tyson here keep looking up